was den a ha haha ich machen video last
light darüber dass mein name ist nicht
willkommen hier heute zu einem video und
ich hab euch mal wieder gesagt wir
sollten die videos ein wenn unter dem
hashtag luca reagiert ab die zahlreich
getan und darauf reagiert ich glaube für
demokratie spannen der situationen
gedacht werden kann ich mich
normalerweise eher weniger ich muss aber
wirklich sagen ich möchte mich jetzt gar
nicht weit aus dem fenster lehnen kann
ich auch gar nicht weil wir hier fliegen
darin haben
ich finde apparat hat sich verbessert ja
ich weiß auch wer gar nicht nur freunde
ich finde wirklich er bleibt rappen er
verbessert sich regelmäßig auf der
anderen seite muss man jedoch anmerken
das ist sehr viel schlecht auch nicht
mehr ging halt seine bisherigen musik
lieder aber er bleibt am ball genauso
ist es bei mir ich spiele derzeit ein
bisschen klavier und lernen darf und bin
auch nicht der beste aber ich hoffe dich
es nicht und er schon andere egal alles
klar besser bescheid nicht auf werbung
für meinen job hier kommt neben ihr auch
den beutel liegen ich hab hier
politikerin strang und ich habe da
wirklich ein paar produkte drehen nicht
meinen dass ein paar t-shirts hocke
deckeln hand wurde in verschiedene
sachen in meinem flotteren airline
naja vielleicht ein bisschen zu hoch
gegriffen aber freunde wisst bescheid
meter katalanisch erstes werk dauert
zwar noch ein bisschen nicht an jetzt
schon klar natürlich war die leistung so
aber vielleicht bin ich dann auch eine
airline in den urlaub fliegen wollten
auf ryanair air berlin flug dr
damit ist man
wer das gemacht du hast du oscar party
ist wirklich selten der fall dass ich in
diese luca reagiert kategorien fitter
rein gehe und videos sehr wo ich
wirklich in la flash millionen davon
nämlich hier der fall
alter und schwarz komplette schallt
video entspannte sich einfach einen
strafbefehl von lkw dran vorbei und ich
meine normalerweise wenn lkw her offene
frage fläche ladefläche kann sind
irgendwelche container drauf oder im
schlimmsten fall irgendwelche schweine
dieser heiteren stehen alle nicht
wirklich auch nicht angewiesen bin ich
zu meiner video angeht ich kann immer
wie meine tochter auch bei meiner
familie auf video von lena in den trend
wo er sich vor eine kamera gekauft hat
60.000 euro kostet ist ca dreimal so
teuer wie mein auto ich meinen
vollkommen in ordnung ist eine gute
investition da ist bestimmt keine video
und dann gibts auch noch mich das ist
meine sache gott so 50 cent ich kann mir
nicht mal hinstellen eine ewigkeit mit
der er so schlecht ist es nicht
eigentlich gar nicht wieder zu sprechen
zu kommen war das richtig ist deutsch
die steht da einfach um und auf einmal
essen lkw dran vorbei mit spongebob und
patrick tanzen darauf was
mega cool megacool location wieder gut
gepflegt ich meine ich das auch gut
fußball spiele ich versuche den mann ab
zu machen
wie kann ich aber nicht bekommen hätte
dankeschön doch ich warte man
[Musik]
normalerweise wenig zu jedem video immer
mal so ein bisschen so wie ich das finde
was ich davon halte fasten teil nach
machen wie gerade bei der mit fußball
fußball sache aber hier kann ich nur
sagen
eine gute entscheidung die sind doch mal
zu besuchen
[Musik]
dann können jetzt sagen ok vandalismus
gepflegt dann aufkleber irgendwo hin was
nicht gehört hat nicht privat ist und
dann vielleicht im anderen gehört oder
öffentlich ist oder so das ist natürlich
in tablettenform strafbar aber es ist
ein dicker aus dem lukas muss ich
wirklich sagen beschweren kann ich mich
normalerweise eher weniger energie
kollege ich habe ja kein luca reagiert
gebraucht wird
frage kannst du eigentlich auch wirklich
ernsthaft aus hass oder bist ein ruhiger
und gelassener mensch tatsächlich eine
ganz interessante frage und war es sehr
sehr viele was du lieber ihren videos
machen auch mittag machte oder ein
bisschen zu krass oder geschafft wieder
keine ahnung was tatsächlich manchmal ob
der fall also es ist jetzt nicht so dass
ich irgendwelche wie das andere youtuber
machen oder ähnliche reaktionen feld
oder so sondern ich bin natürlich immer
ein bisschen aufgeregt wenn die kamera
läuft und bin natürlich ein bisschen
katar drauf und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen dass ich jetzt so im echten leben
das sagen mir auch wenn viele die mich
beim fantreffen treffen
treff treffen treffen die wagen häufig
zu wie hey wenn ich nicht so treffen
bisher mega korrekt mega nett ruhig und
so was irgend alles zufolge lassen gar
nicht so wie wenn ich beispielsweise
horror spiel spiele kann ich meiner
fernsehen natürlich auch logisch das
ganze ist einfach nur menschlich wenn
ich die ganze zeit so ausrasten würde
wie wenn ich beispielsweise damals recht
gut gespielt oder cat mario oder so dann
ja wer mein herz jetzt glaube ich kaputt
und vielleicht vielleicht sogar schon
längst im knast also ich kann natürlich
auch ausgaben nämlich sachen abfangen so
beispielsweise beim fußball denn
irgendwie mein lieblingsverein
rausfliegt oder wenn ich habe den streit
habe oder irgendwie sollen natürlich
auch mal laut werden oder auf raten oder
wenn ich selber irgendwie mich verletzt
oder keine ahnung war aber eigentlich
bin ich eher ein ruhiger mensch und ich
finde auch dass eigentlich alle probleme
konversationen diskussionen eigentlich
nur gelöst werden können wenn man ruhig
bleibt sachlich bleibt freund nein meine
top boxen
[Applaus]
danke für den slow motion video von drei
radfahrern an der stelle jetzt immer
hier in motion video für euch wie winkel
an der filmmusik sagen ich auch
höher ausgefallen in der tat also wort
wenn wir hier zurückzukommen ich finde
es auf jeden fall sehr cool du mein abo
gekündigt hat von der stelle muss ich
sagen da mit einer hd abonniert hat muss
ich wirklich sagen freunde wäre ultra
cool wäre jetzt einfach mal ein abo da
lassen würde die findet unter dem video
einen abonnieren knopf eingewendet mega
event wieder drauflegen würde dazu
draufgelegt hat noch viel besser freunde
da könnte ich einfach daneben da steht
dann abonniert ist eine kleine glocke
eingeblendet darauf könnt ihr nämlich
benachrichtigung an machen wir bekommen
dann bekommen wir eine mitteilung
gewendet so weit ich neu video
hochgeladen habe auch euer handy oder
keine ahnung was das ist
wir wären video eingeblendet von ihnen
einem edelgas im unterricht gefehlt hat
wie eine coladose explodierte so hoch
geflogen ist was nach dem unterricht ich
habe früher auch physik und chemie
gewählt weil ich dachte er macht man
bestimmt irgendwelche trafen bei allen
experimenten mit den lehrern
letztendlich komme dann ein dino
erschaffen sondern eher so eine gebeugte
gemacht aber ich meine ihr flaschen in
die luft hey ich will
[Musik]
ich weiß nämlich dass gerade richtig
gesehen habe aber ich glaube das war das
wirklich eine pizza die da auf dem eis
gefahren ist
[Musik]
ja jetzt kann ich bestätigen dass alle
täter die auf dem ipad zu befahren da
muss ich jetzt wirklich ehrlich gesagt
zu geben die wir pizza hut metternich
also ich meine etwa auch schon mal
schritt zu laufen und na ja vorher steht
zu fallen
bei der nächsten anmeldung hier muss ich
wirklich sagen ich dachte zuerst an
pferden ganz normaler fit bin hat er
sich irgendwie normal gedreht hat und
wir haben ganz normal an gedreht aber
mit sicherheit auch im matheunterricht
aus dem kunstunterricht für aus der
schule oder immer noch in der schule
wahrscheinlich seid ihr sogar noch alle
in der schule gehabt mal auf meisten
zirkel und eine dickere einfach mein
ding anteil und sondern die stadt dran
konnten anspricht reinstecken oder eine
mine und dann konnte man perfekten kreis
gleich sind oder an unserer schule
gehabt wickelt die waren einfach so nah
kommen die ausklappen und konnten so in
rechten kreisen die allerdings in dem
video hat das ganze mit dem feature
spinner gemacht muss ich sagen ja gesagt
die leute die youtube machen und schauen
sind dumm aber ja also vielleicht noch
nicht richtig und ist wahrscheinlich
auch keinen effekt weitere die idee an
sich nicht so dumm wie alt bist du dich
kommt s 2 oder so wenn wir das
angestellt ob schnitzel mit pommes
ob steak mit pommes das bewegt sich so
werden halt wirklich oft so bestimmte
sachen einfach mehr angewendet bei luca
reagiert dass wir jetzt schon youtube
karte eingeblendet wird deshalb ganz
neue liga erreicht wurde
doch interessantes update mit pommes mit
pommes schmecken das komplette scheiße
mit pommes ob sie mitkommen
muss ich wirklich sagen meine damen und
herren beschweren kann ich mich
normalerweise eher weniger zu hause
wir kennen scheiße was uns schnell zu
hause essen wir gern seite was uns
schmeckt nicht aus bin ich auch gern
scheiße was uns schmeckt das ist die
beste werbung die hier für irgendeine
restaurant gehört habe alles schmeckt in
meinem restaurant hat er das wirklich
gesagt es tut mir leid weiter verstärkt
das wenig nämlich auch dass sich das
lauter klatsche vor allem wenn auch
dieses video hier gefallen dann würde
ich mich wehren daumen hoch freunde
findet unter dem video
wie gesagt abonnieren -button eigentlich
beendet da könnte ich hab die brust
geschlagen habt ihr hättet ihr kommt ihr
könnt jetzt in einen kanal abonnieren
oder hier unten meinen stecken jetzt
wenn ich jetzt für andere videos in
berlin und abonnenten die auch die
glocken läuten dann bekommt die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]